alors
oh
ah ah
[Musique]
haïm korsia on parle souvent des racines
judéo chrétiennes de la france ça veut
dire quoi c'est d'abord la diversité
ouais la france ne peut pas s'ancrer
dans quoi que ce soit j'avais
d'uniformes par nature j'ai
consubstantiellement la france est
diverse et judéo chrétienne c'est
d'abord bouscat unis il ya une histoire
avec la chrétienté dans le catholicisme
puis de protestantisme en france bien
aussi une histoire presque dires
antérieurs au christianisme avec le
judaïsme
parce que ces valeurs qui viennent avec
l'église sont portés aussi par la torah
par la bible sont incarnés en france par
une sagesse j'allais presque dire
millénaires qui vient irrigué chacun des
petits villages de france on peut parler
de mme raby moïse de coucy arabe à
narbonne mairie à perpignan rachis 3
donc effet rabbins ont raconté la france
de leur époque quand je parle de rachi
rabbin qui vivait 2040 à 1105 à 3 et qui
a dans ses commentaires
raconter la vie quotidienne des français
de cette époque et utiliser des mots en
français sauf qu'il est écrit en lettres
hébraïques et aujourd'hui c'est la seule
source de
prononciation de la langue qu'on
utilisait à l'époque donc oui il ya ce
grand manteau des églises qui recouvre
la forêt mais il ya quelques synagogue
est justement cette france cette france
des synagogues n'est pas très connue
finalement cette histoire de france
n'est pas très connu peut-être qu'on
encore à faire du chemin pour la raconte
elle expliqué mais prenez l'exemple de
rouen ouais on a le plus ancien monument
qui se trouve sous le palais de justice
de la ville un monument qui était
probablement ce qu'on appelle une
yeshiva une maison d'études il aa +
milan on a est très ancienne synagogue
dans le comtat venaissin ce qu'on
appelait les juges du pape carpentras
cavaillon
on a des traces de judaïsme partout en
france et c'est pas uniquement une
question de traces
c'est que le les jeux m'a apporté aussi
une façon de gérer de voir le monde
d'être en lien avec avec tous je veux
pas accaparer l'histoire de france mais
quand il ya eu des exils notamment les
juifs
portugal et jude espagne oui ils sont
montés pour aller soit en hollande soit
en france choisi e siècle ils se sont
installés par exemple à bayonne
saint-esprit les bayonne perron rade
tous ces anciens cimetières où on a des
traces donc déjà réduit vent avec à
bayonne un ancien migrer un bain rituel
très très ancien de 100 ans à peu près
on a là des gens qui viennent et qui
apporte une part de leur génie qui
devient maintenant le gène de la france
par exemple les juifs ont apporté le
chocolat à bayonne égouttez les et vous
verrez que c'est un apport très
important et alors pour autant il ya
quand même un antisémitisme en france un
sondage qui est sorti ya pas très
longtemps un
institut qui s'appelle l'ifop et qui dit
qu' un français juif sur deux a déjà été
la victime
d'agressions de ta chute
ça vous inquiète pas ça évidemment ça
nous inquiète mais s'inquiète et vu ça
devrait inquiéter l'ensemble de la
société 1 est la grande différence si
vous voulez entre ce qu'on a pu
connaître auparavant oui vers un un
sentiment d'isolement d'enfermement de
roger comme s'il y avait une forme
d'indifférence de la société aujourd'hui
j'ai le sentiment que c'est un des
objectifs importants de ce même sondage
ouais c'est que 60% de tous nos
concitoyens tiers des français considère
que oui il y a un problème
d'antisémitisme en france 60% ça veut
dire que la l'immense majorité de la
société considère qu'on ne lutte pas
assez contre l'antisémitisme qu'on
laisse se propager des préjugés
insupportable là il faut de la fermeté
qu'on peut pas accepter que dès que
quelqu'un s'en prend dé jeu heavy
prétexte la folie les responsabilités on
l'a vu avec docteur sara lee milk
assassiné une manière sauvage et et le
est le coupable parce qu'il est coupable
est exonéré d'un procès où on peut
en
comparaison des choses voir ce qui s'est
passé et donc il ya cette nécessité je
crois de faire de la lutte contente
mutisme une grande cause nationale selon
biz toutes les forces de l'état la
volonté d'état et la volonté de tous nos
concitoyens
alors il ya une devise en france c'est
la liberté égalité fraternité est ce que
vous estimez que cette promesse est
toujours tenu aujourd'hui dans notre
pays
une promesse je vous dire par nature ne
peut jamais être tenue complètement et
c'est peut-être ça la difficulté une
société moins je le vis parce que quand
dieu demande à abraham dans la bible de
quitter sa maison la maison de son père
son pays à khaldé il lui dit va vers une
terre que je t'indique ray il ne dit pas
où il y aura toujours une promesse il y
aura toujours une terre il y aura
toujours une espérance et je pense que
liberté égalité fraternité
ce sont toujours des combats à mener
personne ne peut dire un moment c'est
bien on est au top niveau possible de
liberté d'égalité de fraternité la
meilleure des preuves c'est que on a
encore des combats menés sur l'égalité
entre les hommes et les femmes on a
encore des combats menés pour la liberté
de pouvoir
agir dans certaines conditions ou les
uns aux autres nous en empêche puis la
fraternité on a vu le gap immense qui
nous manquait à combler quand le 11
janvier 2015 plus de 4 millions de
français ont marché dans les rues mais
faire quoi pour dire on veut de la
fraternité ouais parce que si on se bat
pour uniquement liberté égalité en fait
une france réduite aux acquêts vous
défendez pour moi qu'est-ce que je fais
moi pour les autres donc oui je pense
pas qu'on atteigne un niveau optimal de
liberté d'égalité de fraternité ce doit
être un horizon et les horizons les
atteint jamais mais on combat pour
ignorer c'est le principe du rêve de la
république un que de vouloir lutter pour
l'égalité des autres la liberté des
autres et la fraternité
2 - vers les autres et le rôle d'un
grand rabbin là dans ce contexte là
c'est lequel c'est d'abord de chercher
dans une sagesse très ancienne des
moyens d'éclairer le présent ouais souci
d'apporter une part de de la pensée que
je représente comme le font les prêtres
avec les évangiles et pasteur avec
l'évangile lors sagesse eux les
musulmans avec sagesse du coran les
athées avec l'humanisme et tous les
grands textes humanistes dont on partage
au fond une espérance si ce n'est
identiques évidemment c'est impossible
en tout cas une espérance convergentes
et quand par exemple on débat à
l'assemblée au sénat de grands textes
qui touchent la société là on voit
comment le génie français se constituent
avec des apports diverses ouais et la
capacité pour chacun et chacune a
accepté qu'une part de sa vérité meurent
pour laisser la place aux autres la
vérité des autres ouais et c'est ce qui
fait par exemple que la loi leonetti
cnes a été voté la fin de vie oui a été
voté à l'unanimité parce qu'elle a fait
la démonstration que l' écoute des
autres n'est pas l'affrontement d'un
camp contre l'autre avec des punchline
des grandes phrases et c'est la capacité
à rêver la pensée une société où chacun
trouve de quoi se reconnaître parce
qu'il n'y apporte est quelque chose que
je fais moins c'est que j'essaye
d'apporter cette part de jeunes et ils
ont trait cette part de toute
transcendance qui passe aussi par un
humanisme alors justement vous parliez
de fabrication de la loi il ya une loi
qui a fait couler beaucoup d'encre que
la loi dite séparatisme sur le respect
des grands principes de la république
qui est une loi on passe le cachet qui a
été fait pour lutter contre le
radicalisme
islamique et cette loi elle vous
satisfait pas complètement parce que
c'est une loi qui général et qui
évidemment concerne toutes les religions
oui mais il fallait faire quelque chose
était un le temps après l'assassinât du
professeur samuel pâtit il fallait que
la société réagit cette société ne peut
pas dire simplement ça va aller mieux
c'est pas possible il fallait donc
réaffirmer les principes qui nous font
faire société ouais ces principes c'est
liberté l'égalité la fraternité le
respect des autres c'est de ne pas
vouloir vivre complètement en dehors de
la société moi je trouve que cette loi
était nécessaire
elle a été amendée à de très nombreuses
reprises que les cultes ont été associés
très en amont la loi par le gouvernement
tous les cultes ont pu apporter leur
transformation diester dire quand on
fait quelque chose qui relève du culte
on est géré par une association loi 1901
5 ouais mais beaucoup de gens font du
culte avec la loi 1901 il faut mettre
les mêmes contraintes de 1905 sur les
gens qui font du culte et quand même 901
en gros il faut harmoniser les choses
pour mettre du sens c'est toi le fais
pour moi elle était parfaite vous avez
écrit un livre qui s'appelle réinventer
les aurores c'est quoi c'est un
plaidoyer pour la paix pour la
république
oui parce que
je pense que ce rêve républicain on l'a
oublié et victor hugo dans mes pages
magnifiques explique que la révolution
elle n'est jamais fini la révolution
française avec son rêve justement de
mettre la justice d'égalité peut jamais
être atteint et victorieux vous savez de
quoi il parlait les chinois qui ont une
profondeur du temps lorsqu'on leur
demande que pensez-vous de la révolution
française ils y répondent il est encore
un peu tôt pour juger cette vision qui
plongent leurs racines dans le temps et
qui dit les choses avancent peu à peu
donc moi j'essaie de dire on a des
forces incroyable en france on a des
atouts que tous les pays du g4 en vie on
a de la diversité on à l'inventivité on
a une profondeur historique on a de la
littérature qui fait sens et qui fait
lien entre nous tous on a des paysages
d'hiver sont à on a une histoire qui
nous grandit qui nous oblige on a une
présence partout dans le monde avec tous
ces endroits de france partout dans le
monde on incarne quelque chose aux yeux
du monde dans la prière que nous
récitons dans toutes les synagogues
frais les amis frères pour la république
oui disons c'est à la france berceau des
droits de l'homme le défendent en tout
temps et en tout lieu de droit et la
liberté donc défendre la justice au
droit à la liberté c'est aussi une
responsabilité et donc je pense qu'on a
d'immenses chance opportunités et on se
laisse aveugler par quelques faiblesses
quelques j'avais quelques habitudes ce
que serait ce que nous sommes en france
mais une feuille compliqué à comprendre
parfois les débats qui amène pas des
décisions immédiates et efficaces
culture du débat qui débarque de
pragmatisme en détresse fois un peu trop
intellectuel on
on construit une telle vision idéalisée
ou idéologique même parfois d'accord du
monde qu'on a mis devant la réalité
7 l'idéal c'est soif d'idéal dont vous
parlez en france la laïcité d'une
certaine façon c'était ça aussi c'était
ça a été réussi je dirais les des juifs
sont rentrés dans le rang 2 2 de la
république avec le grand nous ne sommes
jamais sortis donc je sais non sens et
drain le grand sens aidera
donc au début du 19e siècle
a fait que les juifs ont
ont accepté de rentrer dans les lois de
la république
je dirais qu'on n'a pas accepté par dont
on a revendiqué on a demandé c'est vrai
que nous sommes citoyens un peu plus
tard que les autres en 1791 de 27
septembre à 91 pas que toi 9 91 mais dès
ce moment là on a fait en sorte de
pouvoir s'engager pleinement pour
construire cette société nouvelle où la
naissance le niveau social ou la
religion n'était plus un frein pour être
simplement citoyen corps et quand
napoléon effectivement début du neuvième
siècle réunion dans 16 1 il pose une
question aux vues fait s'il ya un
conflit de la france contre un pays
étranger vous ferez quoi défendre et la
france et on répond les rabats mon
prédécesseur répond oui jusqu'à la mort
c'est le grand moment david sinzheim et
y signe puis tout un protocole ou impact
aujourd'hui
le grand cèdre est est montrée en
exemple parce que certains se disent on
pourrait faire la même chose justement
pour l'organisation du culte musulman ça
vous paraît possible
il ya de grandes différences entre
judaïsme qui était implanté en france
depuis toujours là vous avez dit ouais
mais là c'est différent c'est une
population qui arrivent de l'extérieur
et qui
veut s'intégrer qui s'intègrent la
république l'a reconnu quand la
république en 1924 construit à ses frais
de nous prendre la loi voilà nous
n'obtenons la loi 1905 a construit la
mosquée de paris pour faire quoi pour
remercier les soldats musulmans redden
de paris à 14 pour nous libérer nous
aider à libérer le territoire national
donc et une histoire aussi qui s'est
construit avec l'islam il faut juste
trouver le moins d'apaiser le débat et
de ré fermé des valeurs fermes claires
nettes n'est pas de possibilité d'avoir
ce que quelqu'un comme et je veux rendre
hommage à son amie très peu de temps
quelqu'un comme laurent bouvet appelé
l'insécurité culturel en fait une sorte
sentiment de ne plus reconnaître des
espaces de vie de ne plus reconnaître
le mode de vie de l'habitus et la
laïcité n'a rien à voir c'est l'habitude
c'est en fait la façon d'être dans le
respect de ce que l'autre peut attendre
de moi et que moi ce que je peux
attendre de lui qu'en fait il ya surtout
une question de
de respect de la société la laïcité et
les loyers noah avec arne est simple et
encore certains interprètent
différemment en revanche le respect
c'est quelque chose qui est de l'ordre
personnel c'est comme la fraternité d'où
la difficulté la fraternité il n'y a pas
une norme de fraternité c'est un élan
vers l'autre et bien le respect c'est
aussi un élan vers l'autre des citoyens
nos concitoyens et concitoyennes
musulmans et musulmanes s'insère
parfaitement dans la société aujourd'hui
mais sans problème certes la question se
pose pour celles et ceux qui refusent
cette vision d'une france uff pluriel
alors il faut le rappeler les règles
comment vous accepter le fait que l'on
dit et pour interdire le voile par
exemple on interdit aussi la kippa c'est
une idiotie majeur
chacun droit de proférer des idioties le
danger c'est quand on vote pour ceux qui
profèrent c'est aussi
le voile et la kippa sont deux choses
différentes l'équipe a vocation à être
discrète le voile est sorti la sphère
religieuse pour entendre à leur
politique l'affirmation non maintenant
je vois bien que aussi à la liberté qui
face au ch liberté et dans l'héritage
des lumières aussi oui mais dans
l'espace public il ya la liberté de
s'habiller comme on a mis des limites à
l'école pour la traiter et les agents de
l'état et où donc vouloir interdire un
signe religieux quel qu'il soit par une
grande croix une soutane
le voile des bonnes soeurs qui pour moi
le symbole de la bonté infinie on va
qu'on va devoir quand on est un officier
d'une religion est un laïc ça n'a rien à
voir aussi mais si on interdit le si on
interdit ainsi nos imaginaires
interdisent les signes religieux dans
l'espace public ce sera tous les signes
religieux et comment vous établissez un
chapeau avec la plume ça compte où ça
compte pas avec la plume c'est un
chapeau bavarois sans la plus mince ça
devient un chapeau religieux n'en finira
plus donc on voit bien que c'est quelque
chose d'impossible parce que ça touche à
la liberté et la société est libre
cirque ont pu s'habiller comme on veut à
l'extérieur ils tant que ça encore une
fois ça ne choque pas les habitudes
voilà pourquoi on a une loi qui interdit
la burqa intégral qui laisse la liberté
aux femmes de porter le voile maintenant
on a le dos en france d'avoir des débats
étonnant et moi j'ai toujours été
stupéfait que on se bagarre pour
interdire aux mamans qui accompagnent
les sorties scolaires voire un foulard
d'être contre sera joué dans les andes
est censé maman qui prennent de leur
temps tu aurais pas la sortie scolaire
donc elles n'ont pas un geste trop élite
donc elles sont dans leur liberté et on
n'a pas attentats et la liberté de
laïcité militante mais moi je suis très
laïque au sens que je respecte
n'oublions pas qu'à loi la ftc liberté
de pratique religieuse et neutralité de
l'état une fois qu'on on est là c'est
simple liberté de pratique religieuse
c'est pas une loi qui interdit c'est une
loi qui randonnent la liberté de
pratique religieuse avec la limite de la
une près de l'état et votre liberté
sursis ma liberté au jeu vient empiéter
la vôtre alors c'est là la limite ont
écouté la banque avait une certaine idée
de la france vous allez le reconnaître
tout de suite
je me fais en effet de la france une
certaine idée
je veux dire par là qu'à mon sens elle
est quelque chose
de très grand de très particulier
c'est du reste je pense ressentie par le
monde entier
c'est vrai la france est une chose à mes
yeux
très considérable très valable et
elle doit avoir dans le monde quels
qu'ils soient toutes époques
naturellement d'après les circonstances
elle doit avoir un rôle à elle
il faut que la france joue son rôle
c'est exact et pour qu'elle joue son
rôle il faut qu'elle soit la france
les français des français ceux qui font
la france
c'est eux qui en sont responsables
la france est plus que les français du
moment
la france vient de loin
vient de loin la france et l'europe et
elle va loin vous êtes confiant sur son
1 sa solidité elle est plus de ya plus
de 60 ans que général de gaulle a dit ça
oui c'était en 1965 on est entre les
deux tours de l'élection présidentielle
la première au suffrage universel direct
selon temps on voit bien que c'est
toujours la déviation de la france
regardez nous sommes partis dans
trois quarts des grands échanges
internationaux nous sommes là le conflit
entre les arméniens d'azerbaïdjan
on est là dans le groupe de minsk entre
les ukrainiens et les russes président
qui va essayer de trouver un terrain
d'entente donc la france on a un réseau
diplomatique immense on a des
implications partout dans le monde on a
nos soldats qui vont au mali quoi qu'on
pense au sahel louis
djamena on est partout dans le monde on
a on a défendu
nos valeurs partout où vous en êtes fier
de ça je trouve que c'est une forme de
grandeur aussi de ne pas considérer
qu'on défende juste le petit pré carré
on n'est pas dans la théorie mon euros d
amérique d'amérique et de la moitié du
20e siècle on est vraiment dans une
logique
de responsabilité envers le monde entier
de le note droit d'asile est un droit
important qu'il fonde ce que nous sommes
notre combat pour défendre des chrétiens
d'orient est un combat presque honte aux
logiques de ce qu'est la france parce
que c'est notre responsabilité
historique depuis toujours alors qu'ils
sont abandonnés par là tous les pays du
monde donc moi je raisonne à ce que dit
le g1 de gaulle parce que c'est comme ça
que je vois la france parfois le général
de gaulle a quand même eu enfin la
france a eu des paroles qui ont pu
blesser en 1967 après la guerre des six
jours quand le général de gaulle parle
du peuple juif sûr de lui et dominateur
et ça ça marquer quand même une rupture
aussi avec notamment l'aider oui il
glisse de france j'ai beaucoup travaillé
sur cette question parce que j'ai eu la
chance d'avoir accès aux archives près
dans le gault et l'otan mais je suis
venue l'idée de cette époque et on voit
que c'est une des rares pour ne pas dire
la seule fois au général de gaulle et
essaye de faire marche arrière c'est un
peu compliqué il aux prêts à voir ça oui
un peu d'élite sûr de lui et dominateur
la plus belle des réponses et celle de
team qui montre une étoile de david ne
décélère il fit dessine une étoile david
en barbelés et un
déporté obtenu des portes et le pied sur
les barbelés qui dit sûr de lui et
dominateur
qu'il faut faut voir aussi ce que ça
voulait dire l'époque et d'ailleurs
c'est la rupture avec ce texte
incroyable dehors et moi wrong way i
dans un texte brûlant ardent répond à de
gaulle en disant non ça c'est pas
possible c'est pas et dire il faut
comprendre d'où vient cette expression
même si les gaullistes historiques vont
essayer de nous expliquer que au
contraire c'est laudateur pour le peuple
israël sûr de lui j'aimerais que les
français le dreff à eux aussi pour la
réalité c'est que ça porte aussi une
part de préjugés qui montre d'ailleurs
d'une certaine manière a contrario la
grandeur du général de gaulle qui venait
d'un milieu qui était pas a priori porté
sur le philosémitisme et pourtant il
vient d'une famille dreyfusarde
dreyfusarde c'est à dire qu' une famille
qui se bat contre son milieu pour dire
non cet officier français est innocent
et le général de gaulle j'ai retrouvé un
quelque chose magnifique il ya quelqu'un
qui doit être nommé ambassadeur
je crois que tu es en jordanie et on le
dit en général il ya un petit problème
c'est que c'est le neveu du capitaine
dreyfus et répond parfait c'est donc le
neveu d'un officier de l'armée française
qu'on nomme et tout est là
cette lutte pour réaffirmer que chacun
chacune dans sa diversité
deux fois ou d'absence de foi
constituent la trame et la chaîne de ce
qu'est la france
alors la france justement je voudrais
que vous la symbolise y est d'une
certaine façon avec ce qu'on appelle le
questionnaire de proust
si c'était un paysage ça serait quoi la
france pour vous mais je vous ai parlé
la diversité fait à la fois les
montagnes le mont blanc le plus haut
sommet d'europe ouais la mer un des plus
grands depuis monte gober on a un peu de
tout alors là c'est mais c'est ça aussi
la levée le blé de la nourrit la france
et qui est notre force notre richesse
c'est fait pommier ces arbres fruitiers
elle procède de ses paysages à vous avez
mis cette diversité de paysages c'est là
ce qui fait que d'abord on a reçoit
tentées tant le million d habitude mais
que quel que soit notre aspiration on
trouve quelque chose qui nous touche qui
nous habite dans tous les paysages de
france si c'était à un écrivain
c'est victor hugo victor hugo vous en
avez parlé tout à l'heure victor une
oeuvre en particulier tous victor hugo
nous bouleverse 1 ses poèmes
les contemplations quelqu'un capable
d'écrire dans les contemplations la
dette était si grande qu'il ne pouvait
l'a payée que par l'ingratitude a tout
dit mais dans les misérables vous avez
quelque chose de d'incroyablement
contemporain cette façon de voir opposer
des castes et clans et les clans est
quelqu'un qui vient et qui dit non on va
faire du lien on va rassembler vos
histoires pour créer une espérance
commune ça c'est le meilleur bleu
si c'était une toile
une toile de soulages soulage parce que
soulage voilà oui d'abord sous la selle
un de nos plus grands peintres je trouve
que d'avoir fait émerger la lumière de
l'obscurité d'avoir cette façon avec des
des traits
de remplir une infinie
10 p vous avez à la fois du rêve et vous
avez l'espace dans les interstices de la
toile pour imaginer quelque chose alors
prêts chacun peut le voir comme il
l'entend et devrait me diront ccc simple
moi je trouve qu'il ya infiniment de de
recherche et deux de sérénité dans ses
toiles et il a mis du temps à trouver
son style soulage dans non parce que oui
ça c'est les années 50 je réponds oui
mais les accords de 60 à d'apartés
années 80 il a fait des grands des
grandes toiles complètement noir avec
l'outrenoir et il a ensuite fait une
oeuvre incroyable à à conques il a fait
les vitraux de l'abbaye de conques vrai
il a inventé un alliage d'aluminium il
m'a raconté ça
pour faire un verre particulier qui
laisse parfois passer la lumière et qui
l'empêchent de bafé est donc juste avec
du blanc et du noir il a recréé la
diversité humaine je trouve que ces
formes génial de vision du monde
est alors pour finir si c'était un
personnage historique ce serait lequel
j'aime beaucoup rachis alors rachis
rashif un rabbin ouais qu'ils lui disent
tu oui il a vous l'avez dit il a
commenté la bible et le talmud way à
partir de sa traduction son
interprétation de la bible donc c'est
hors 11e siècle exactement 1 il mord
1105 nicolas de lire 13e va s'inspirer
de son commentaire pour traduire la
bible de l'hébreu aux français ouais et
on va passer on va éviter l'attribution
de gros grec à 70 du grec au latin la
vulgate élus latins aux français brand
content qu'elle comme perdition
séraphine qui va inspirer toutes les
traductions ensuite à travers celle de
nicolas de lire il joue lily va nous
permettre de connaître la la
prononciation du français de l'époque et
hiva nous font trouver des aspirations
communes entre ce qu'est
l'âme judaïsme et ce qu'est l'âme de la
france est-ce qu'on se rend pas compte
que dans le monde entier quiconque
étudie la bible ou le tlm une y compris
pour les non juifs qui étudie la bible
avec les commentaires de rachi
l'étudient à travers le filtre d'un ram
un français c'est à dire avec le génie
du mot juste quelle spécialité du
français avec le génie de l'allusion de
l'imaginaire français et puis il était
vigneron c'est à dire qu'il était dans
la connaissance de la terre de ce
souffle de la terre de france pour moi
c'est alors oui c'est l'un des plus
grands français de l'histoire ait eu un
timbre à son effigie son nom figure sur
le frontispice de la bibliothèque sainte
geneviève tu peux être que nos
concitoyens devraient se souvenir un peu
plus de lui s'en souvient pas il n'est
pas assez connu
l'interview rabat rachis il est merci
merci m korcia merci beaucoup
[Musique]